the reality is it's just all in your
mind this is a very interesting point of
view that might really help at the end
of the day the thing I think that makes
me not scared is I know that all of them
don't care let me explain what I mean by
that at the end of the day everybody
else is worried about their own life so
if you stumble if you stink yeah they
may leave a comment here and there but
deep down they don't care but knowing
they don't care is actually liberating
for you to do you understand no it's not
that serious to everybody else thus it
should be easy for you to do because
their judgment shouldn't matter to you
because you have to realize it doesn't
matter to them and you just need to
change these mindset and you change it
and that's it or it's a practice both
fixed Minds it's a fixed mindset to get
you to start once you start you realize
it's not that scary people were scared
to ride bikes people were scared to swim
people were scared to kiss a boy and a
girl they were scared then they did it
they weren't scared that's it